stasera vi parlerò di un
un qualcosa di abbastanza particolare di
un hobby che non può più di un hobby di
una filosofia che è profondamente
radicata in questo orbi diciamo noi lo
chiamiamo am spirit dovevamo in questo
caso non è ovviamente un prosciutto ma è
il nomignolo che noi con i quad
normalmente tra gli amatori ci
identifichiamo permettetemi anche di
spiegare un pochino nella di amatore che
non siamo molto noti in generale è uno è
portato a pensare che chiunque parli per
radio chiacchieri per radio sia tra gli
amatori
in realtà la cosa è molto più complessa
perché tre armatori e un servizio
esattamente come tutti gli altri servizi
come la radiotelevisione servizio
marittime scriviti aereo così come
definito dalla hit you che la compagnia
internazionale delle telecomunicazioni
che dà una definizione molto chiara e un
servizio di radiocomunicazione a scopo
di autoformazione comunicazioni interne
indagini tecniche effettuate da amatori
ovvero persone debitamente autorizzate
interessate alla tecnica della radio
esclusivamente a scopo personale attente
interesse economico
quindi diciamo che quello che ci muove è
un interessi tipo sono sostanzialmente
scientifico
la differenza rispetto alla ai servizi
professionali e che noi non siamo
motivati da nessun tipo di interesse
economico ma solamente di conoscenza
personale quindi sostanzialmente di
interesse tecnico siamo in larga parte
autocostruttori quindi costruiamo le
apparecchiature che utilizziamo e dove
il termine amatori è da intendersi non
come dilettante che dalle nostre parti
normalmente non è un termine
diciamo che
spesso utilizzati in contrapposizione a
professionisti per dire qualcheduno che
le cose le fai in maniera non corretta
ma come esattamente come non
professionista noi siamo persone che le
cose che fanno le fanno per diretto per
diventare di amatori bisogna fare degli
esami successivamente una volta superati
degli esami e di natura tecnica di
natura legislativa sia una licenza con
la licenza
stiamo nominativo che quegli 80 che
avete visto che il mio nominativo che
sostanzialmente una targa che noi usiamo
ogni qualvolta operiamo via radio
attualmente noi abbiamo allocate tutte
una banda di una serie di bande di
frequenza dalle onde lunghissima le
microonde che si contendono di fare
sperimentazione perché lo scopo abbiamo
essenzialmente è uno scopo di
sperimentazione chiaramente stando agli
amatori per fare collegamento dobbiamo
essere almeno in due
questo ci ha spinto a mettere a punto un
codice una serie di un codice etico
anche se non lo potremmo definire così
che è stato scritto da un radioamatore
nel 1928 radioamatori americana insieme
alla pole se gallo whisky 9 come corsa
che ha scritto questa questa serie di
regole la quella che ci interessa di più
fra tutte quante è la regola numero 8
che dice che il radioamatore deve essere
amichevole si adegua le capacità del
corrispondente da consigli e notizie i
principianti offre cortese assistenza e
collaborazione verso gli interessi di
altri degli amatori questo sono i
requisiti e la spirit che significa che
nel nostro campo chi fa il radioamatore
comunque né verso altri dagli amatori a
dei rapporti assolutamente informali e
sempre pronto ad ammettere a condividere
la propria conoscenza e che due persone
ci sia caso mai dalla parte un premio
nobel
dall'altra parte uno studente non fa
nulla perché nel momento in cui si parla
si parla di radio di tutto ciò e del
connesso il caso lo stesso livello sullo
stesso piano
le competenze professionali vengono
condivisi in ambito amatoriale c'era una
grande forza dell'associazionismo noi
italiani forse in questo siamo meno
bravi però nel mondo in generale le
associazioni dei donatori sono molto
forte ed è un metodo che è stato messo a
punto fosse in maniera naturale per
garantirci la crescita perché ovviamente
lavorando in attività che io definisco
di frontiera cioè in zone della
comunicazione che casomai non sono state
ancora esplorate da nessuno o ai questo
metodo
quindi o tu sei disponibile a dare la
tua conoscenza
per averne in cambio la conoscenza
dell'altro quindi mettere insieme le
forze e crescere oppure non si va da
nessuna parte è un allenamento fetta di
radioamatori oggi è impegnato nella
sperimentazione di frontiera
però in questo discorso che pregano di
fare un fall cominciamo un sacco con la
fantasia con la memoria la memoria che
per chi ha la metà di quando non
esistevano i telefonini non c'era
internet si andava solo con le cabine
telefoniche ed era anche difficile fare
le telefonate in dalle selezioni per chi
è più giovane di immaginare questo mondo
che oggi è diventato anche strano perché
siamo tutti connessi tutti quanti
abbiamo abbiamo la propaggine che ci
collega al resto del mondo ma così non è
stato e vedremo dopo anche oggi in
qualche situazione così come l'idea di
costruire un satellite radioamatoriale è
nata a radon the beach club
il radon è un presunto beach un sobborgo
di los angeles nel 1958 poco dopo il
lancio dell'ex por el 1 che è quello
stata elite che vedete qui sopra è stato
il primo statunitense è sostanzialmente
stato il primo satellite scientifico
essere messo in orbita venne a questo
gruppo di radioamatori di questo club
perché tra loro c'erano tecnici dell'ati
arda video che è un'azienda impegnata
nel settore missilistico e dei temi
conduttori e costruiva il booster
atlas che è stato uno dei primi
lanciatori della storia del re della
aerospaziale americana e della lockheed
che invece facevano il secondo stadio
che si chiamava agen a questo gruppo
insieme a un altro gruppo di università
americana dietro la vita a quello che ti
chiamava project oscar dove oscar è un
acronimo a sugli americani sono molto
cari che stava per ordita in satelight
che arringa materadio cioè satellite
orbitante che porta apparecchiatura
della terra di amatori progetto che
nacque nel 1959 con un'idea molto folle
che era quella di sostituire delle dita
board che venivano utilizzate per
riequilibrare il carico dei missili con
un sapere tasti ficiale costruito dai
radioamatori
tenete presente che all'epoca non
esisteva la missilistica civile nel caso
particolare non c'era ancora manco la
rata tutto questa operazione veniva
fatta dai militari
quindi era un processo e tremende
complesso perché rendetevi conto siamo
in un momento in cui l'america aveva
lanciato ancora il suo primo missile
tutto era fatto in ambito militare
stiamo nel periodo d'oro della corsa
allo spazio però questi ci pensava non
solo mette a lavorare ci hanno messo tre
anni per fare questo discorso questo che
vedete è il capo progetto di questo
gruppo si chiamava lancianti chiama
perché tuttora vivo vanta killer ed era
un tecnico della lockheed assieme ai
colleghi della tier dario era di ardabil
che ha fornito gratuitamente i
transistor utilizzate uno star finale
statelli te si sono messi a costruire
quella quell'aggeggio che vedete sotto
le mani della di lance che vedete a una
forma molto strana perché era fatto
proprio sostituire una zavorra quindi
ungari dove sarebbe andato perso
era la prima volta che qualcuno pensava
di lanciare un satellite come carico
secondario cioè nel senso che prima in
quegli anni
visto che l'esperienza anche
relativamente poco i lanci mi avevano
fatto un uniti da un satellite
quindi non esistevano neppure i
meccanismi per poter espellere questo
questo prodotto ebbero una grande idea
di costruire un sofisticato meccanismo
acquistando una molla da un locale
negozio di hardware un wall mart che
costa la bellezza di un euro e 68
centesimi
morale della favola il satellite costò
tutto completo solo 70 dollari ma vedete
una versione di uno delle prove che sta
in un museo
in america è andato in orbita il 12
dicembre 1961
caso strano a siamo un satellite corona
che era un satellite spia americano due
o tre settimane perché andava a batterie
queen dopo settimane le batterie si
scaricavano trasmise un messaggio in
codice morse che foris ricevuto da più
di 600 agli amatori tutto il mondo è
stato il primo satellite non governativo
il primo satellite commerciale potremmo
utilizzare questo termine è aperto alla
state dei cosiddetti piggyback saltate
light che sarebbero i carichi secondari
che oggi sono diventati un meccanismo
normale per lanciare satelliti dallo
spazio
quella che vedete samantha cristoforetti
sulla che una di amatrice anche lei z 0
di f mentre quella scatola blu e
trasmettitore a tv che sta a bordo della
iss la stazione spaziale internazionale
che è stato costruito dame startitalia e
che serve per trasmettere una sorta di
digitale terrestre però in questo caso
amatoriale immagini in in immagini
televisive
la stazione è stata leader nazionale a
un progetto che si chiama harris che
serve per trasportare
[Musica]
il sogno dello spazio delle scuole
prevede una the di collegamenti che ha
fatto tramite la di amatore che harris
sta per amateur radio on air stesso che
sarebbe la stazione spaziale
internazionale sviluppare in ambito
spaziale non è solo mettere in ordine di
statalità ma questo poi diventa una
palestra di studio e di conoscenza per
chi da terra questa terra e te lo deve
operare
ma passiamo a una palestra un poco più
ha detto ogni un po più terra terra
torniamo sulla terra parliamo di
comunicazione digitale e questa è la mia
stazione all'incirca nel 1988 all 80 e
all 81
come detto sulla destra ci sono le
apparecchiature sulla sinistra c'è un
home computer di quegli anni per la una
delle prime volte al di fuori dei grossi
sistemi di calcolo il calcolatore un'ora
più uno strumento per fare i conti ma
deve andare uno strumento di
comunicazione con il software
noi utilizziamo quelle macchine per
collegarci 1 a 1
quindi dietro una tastiera ce l'ho io
dall'altra parte c'è il mio
corrispondente quello che scrivo io
appariva sul monitor del corrispondente
quello che assieme a lui appariva sul
mio monitor
il passaggio successivo quale è stato
logico quello di passare a sistemi
automatici e come questa era una delle
aree di frontiera quindi aree nelle
quali non è che uno andava al negozio
dice scusate mirate un sistema di questo
genere veniva fuori quel discorso che
facevo prima che era quello della spirit
per fatto di condividere quindi di dire
quello che la mia esperienza e la mette
a disposizione degli altri
questo è un progetto e un mio progetto
che prevedeva chi ha la realizzazione
dell'hardware necessario perché comunque
serviva un po di elettronica per fare
questo discorso sia di software che era
dato in maniera completamente aperta
quindi ognuno poteva prendere il
software integrarlo modificarlo a farlo
e farne quello che voleva fu così che
dalle nel nostro ambito cominceranno a
nascere le bibbie e bbf cosa sono oggi
come oggi
parliamo di archeologia informatica ma
non esiste né attraverso cui ognuno
poteva collegarsi a questa mattina
tramite un computer e un modem prima in
campo radio poi in campo telefonico
lasciare messaggi leggere messaggi di
altri quale fu il passo successivo la
ditta disponibilità dei modem e dei
modem intelligenti cosiddetti smart
modem che potevano essere collegati al
calcolatore e programmati questo questa
persona che vedete sulle spalle e un
invadente informatico americano tom
jennings che è stato la prima persona
che ha detto ma perché non proviamo a
collegare un b b s con un altro ea
cercare di costruire una rete
nasceva python è questo che vedete sulle
spalle e il welcome back stage del della
mia bbf che è stata la prima bbs
italiana e jennings ha dichiarato in
maniera esplicita quando ha avuto l'idea
di dire colleghiamo queste due macchine
l'una all'altra
l'ha fatto con lo spirito della di
amatori e proprio ha usato questo
termine in effetti noi abbiamo ereditato
questa questa questa filosofia
abbiamo
implementati in maniera completa in
quella che era la
la logica di fondo di questa ricca ed
omettere a una serie di bbs che venivano
che venivano installate su dei
normalissimi pc gli utenti potevano
collegarsi a questo abbs qui vedete un
le videate dico di come funzionavano le
cose
collegandosi autenticandosi nome utente
e password come facciamo attualmente con
tutti i sistemi che utilizziamo anche
oggi
uno aveva a disposizione una serie di
aree di comunicazione nel senso che
c'erano delle aree pubbliche dove uno
poteva lasciare messaggi che venivano
letti da tutti quindi sostanzialmente
non delle aree di discussione tematica
facendo un riferimento abbastanza
normale un po come i gruppi facebook per
intenderci dove che c'erano delle aree
di messaggistica privata nel senso che
ogni cliente utente poteva scrivere ad
un altro utente è chiaramente più o meno
come i messaggi di posta elettronica
c'erano delle aree i file quelle che
vedete in basso che era invece dave del
dei grossi contenitori grossi per
l'epoca parliamo di qualche decina di
megabyte in cui si potevano lasciare
file documenti e qualsiasi cosa fosse
l'interesse comune
stiamo parlando dell 85 in questo 85 86
quindi i tempi in cui ripeto internet
non esisteva ancora e arpanet stata
ancora in condizione particolare
considerate che l'italia si è collegata
ad arpanet attraverso i croce repeat
nell'aprile dell 86
l'unica regola che ci gestiva dal punto
di vista diciamo della relazione sociale
era una policy che era basata su due
concetti molto chiari non ci si non si
deve disturbare troppo gli altri non ci
si deve cercare troppo facilmente che
sembra una banalità che però nell'atto
pratico unita alla presenza del sito fa
la moderazione delle aree ha fatto sì
che almeno in italia non avessimo
problemi
quali ricordi più belli che uno può
avere a distanza di tanto tempo e che
tante delle persone con cui abbiamo
condiviso questa esperienza
io sono stato coordinatore fino al 92 ma
dopo di che sono state ancora qualche
altro anni in rete
tuttora oggi siamo rimasti in contatto
e ricordiamo con grande piacere
quest'epoca questo questo periodo quindi
questo dimostra che poi alla fine
poche regole che lo spirito è quello
giusto possano metterci nella condizione
di fare cose che altrimenti da soli non
saremmo mai stati in grado di fare ora
da un ricordo bello quale può essere
questo passiamo un ricordo che
sicuramente molto più angosciante porti
di blocco
ma le decorazioni per tutto
vediamo vediamo
[Musica]
questa che avete sentito sono
comunicazioni che sono state registrate
la te la prendere se la tela del 24 di
novembre quando potenza e tutta l'area
del interessata dal sisma
infine basilicata fu colpito dal
terremoto
i radioamatori hanno avuto sempre
un'attenzione molto viva verso il
proprio territorio
nel decalogo c'è un punto specifico che
dice il radioamatore deve essere
impegnato per la propria città per la
propria rete per la propria comunità e
per la propria nazione e allargherei il
discorso al mondo tutto fin dal 1951
quella che vedete in alto la sinistra
sono radioamatori su una barca
nell'alluvione del polesine sulla destra
ricordi dell'alluvione di firenze del 68
ma quello che diciamo ci ha fatto più
specificatamente pensare che era
necessario organizzarsi in maniera
pratica e stata l'esperienza del
servizio fatto in occasione del
terremoto del friuli nel 1976 ci siamo
dotati all'epoca di un corpo che si ma
la corto emergenza degli amatori cerra
perché l'attività di attività di
assistenza in caso di emergenza non si
improvvisa non è una cosa che si può
fare in maniera estemporanea tutta una
serie di elementi che vanno considerati
ve ne cito solo alcuni innanzitutto
bisogna essere completamente autonomi
dal punto di vista del vitto
dell'alloggio dell'alimentazione perché
chiaramente nelle apparecchiature hanno
bisogno di energia elettrica
altrimenti si è d'intralcio bisogna
avere capacità
di allestire i sistemi di comunicazione
perché dipendono da quelle che sono le
esigenze del territorio
bisogna avere una cosa che sembra una
banalità ma è quella di comunicare senza
alterare il messaggio cioè nel senso che
io devo esser in grado come radioamatore
i fasti che un messaggio parta e arrivi
a destinazione senza essere modificato
senza perdere delle parti o sente che
altre parti ne vengano aggiunge il
il risultato di questa di questa di
questa di questa esperienza è stato
quello di aver contribuito nella maniera
che potevamo avere per portare soccorso
alle nostre popolazioni
vi ringrazio buona serata